frente a la entrada de la ciudadela inca
de machu picchu cientos de turistas se
agolpan algunos de ellos intentan saltar
las barreras de seguridad una suspensión
de la venta de entradas para acceder al
sitio ha enfadado a los comerciantes y a
los turistas
muy mal organizado todo lo que pueden
[Música]
por de las maravillas del mundo estemos
pasando estos malos momentos por la
incapacidad de nuestras autoridades
que es muy mal
nadie lo sabe
una estafa
vender a los extranjeros
el momento
pictures
si bien las autoridades no han dado
ninguna explicación sobre la suspensión
las entradas a machu picchu están
sujetas a cuotas una medida tomada en
2019 para proteger este patrimonio
arqueológico construido en una montaña
en el siglo 15 al inicio entraron 3.000
visitantes cada día la cuota ahora es de
5 mil personas después de una primera
manifestación contra la suspensión de
las entradas hace dos semanas una cifra
que sigue siendo insuficiente para
gestionar el flujo de visitantes que
regresaron en masa tras la pandemia